hello everyone I'm Dana Perino along
with judge Janine Pio Jessica tarlo
Jesse Waters and Greg Gutfeld it's 5:00
in New York City and this is the
[Music]
P EMB battled Harvard president Claudine
gab resigning as the leader of the most
powerful Ivy League school in the
country it took both her disastrous
anti-Semitism testimony before Congress
and 50 allegations of plagiarism to end
the shortest president in the
University's history just 6 months gay
not mentioning either of those scandals
in a statement but seems to imply that
racism was a factor in her ouster she
said it was quote frightening to be
subjected to personal attacks and
threats fueled by racial animists Gaye
downall started when she could not
answer this question in front of
Congress so the answer is yes that
calling for the genocide of Jews
violates Harvard code of conduct correct
it depends on the context it does not
depend on the context the answer is yes
and this is why you should resign
congresswoman Alise stonic says gay
stepping down is only the
beginning we have seen a failure of
leadership from Claudine gay a failure
of moral leadership but also a failure
of academic Integrity which is a
Cornerstone of any higher education
institution I believe as we continue our
Congressional investigation we will
uncover what will be the greatest
scandal in higher education because the
Harvard Corporation members themselves
are complicit in this cover up of her
plagiarism and again most importantly
their failure to protect Jewish students
on campus no word yet from former
president Barack Obama who privately
lobbied on Harvard president Claud and
Gay's behalf during the anti-Semitism
controversy but we are hearing from the
Reverend Al Sharpton he said this this
is an attack on every black woman in
this country country who's put a crack
in the glass ceiling it's an assault on
the health strength and future of
diversity equity and inclusion at a time
when Corporate America is trying to back
out of billions of dollars in
commitments despite resigning as
president gay is still on the payroll as
a faculty member she just doesn't have
to do the president's job anymore so
many different angles here um one thing
Greg we should point out I think is that
the Washington Free Beacon was the one
who was pointing out all of this
plagiarism based on Old Sho leather
reporting that was available to any
other media Outlet The Washington Post
could have done it but it was the
Washington Free Beacon who really that's
what's so funny about her uh I mean it's
not a surprise that she claims racism
that she's a victim of racism for losing
her job after this moral implosion at
the hearing and then this countless
examples of plagiarism and some made by
black Scholars and yet it's still racism
no Mrs gay or M gay it wasn't racism
that cost you the job it was racism that
got you the job right any white person
had her pedigree they wouldn't be
running a school of fish and this is the
problem with Dei and ESG is that
everything that it infects it destroys
whether it's Academia corporations the
military if you designate a small group
out of a larger general population as
the preferred higher you force every
recruiter to go to that select group and
the supply cannot meet the demand it's a
math problem so you end up being forced
to hire what's left even if that person
is not qualified or even competent it's
a it's mathematical racism and you
choose an inet candidate over somebody
else who's far better because they don't
fit the right color that choice however
makes it harder for places like Harvard
and any company to fire somebody even if
they are ripe for firing and you know
it's funny funny it really isn't Gay's
fault because the system awarded her
into a slot that was beyond her current
capabilities because of her skin color
if you make a deal with the Dei devil
you're going to die by the with the
accusation of racism so everybody made
this bed I love the fact that they all
have to sleep in it watch this take from
Matt Egan he was on
CNN we should note that um claudon gay
has not been accused of stealing
anyone's ideas in any of her writings uh
she's been accused of sort of more like
copying uh other people's writings
without attribution so it's been more
sloppy attribution than stealing
anyone's ideas judge what is the
definition of plagiarism I I have to
close my mouth before I can answer that
Dana plagiarism is actually that it's a
taking of other people's ideas and words
um and the amazing part of this is that
there are 50 credible allegations of
plagiarism and when you look back into
the history of Claudine gay you realize
the woman has never even published a
book she has written nothing uh that has
any seminal contributions to her field
according to people have looked at at
her Brett Stevens in particular in 26
years she's written 11 articles I mean
it's incredible but what the what the
problem is here is that she was held to
a different standard than other students
at Harvard and there was an article that
was written a letter to the editor of
the crimson in the newspaper at har
Harvard and a person who um was
responsible for quote upholding the
standards of academic Excellence said it
would be the worst day when the kid at
Harvard had to come before our committee
that person would cry they might be
suspended they would have a a a tarnish
on their record and yet she's got 50 of
them and what did they do they they
relev they relegated her to you know
this system at this level where as
president she wasn't touched and I think
that her race has advantaged her and the
fact that she has in no way been held to
account for not protecting others is the
ultimate hypocrisy hypocrisy when you
see in her statement when she's leaving
she says it is so frightening to find
myself the target of threats well if you
had any intelligence you would
understand that the reason you are where
you are is because you didn't protect
others who were the targets of real
threats and finally we should realize
that Harvard was started in 1698 as a
Divinity School and that there were
people who were who went there to learn
about religion and Divinity it was non-
denominational so repeated numerous
violations she didn't deserve to be
there in the first place and I'm glad
she's gone and one of the things that
the Divinity School and other schools
should teach is you help develop the
character yeah of the person and so
taking responsibility and being
accountable for your actions is one of
those things things Harvard is still
half-heartedly defending her Jessica and
the pain is not going to end for the
school until they acknowledge the
wrongdoing because there's the
plagiarism issue but it's almost as if
the
anti-Semitism was fine like that was
excused after the hearing but it was the
plagiarism that got her in the
end I think that she suffered from and
all three of the presidents who showed
up at the hearing suffered from an
attack of legal Le right they just went
as if they had no soul right and this is
what the lawyers who pre me for this
said and I would encourage everyone
there was a really interesting piece in
the New York Times about how the
president of Colombia has avoided
falling into this because they had the
the campus was Rife with Pro Palestinian
protests there were professors that were
speaking on and she has really kind of
studied the ship and one thing that she
ended up doing was not going to that
testimony she was invited to sit there
with the rest of them and she had to be
at a climate change conference it was
already sorry climate change that will
excuse everything I next time Jesse say
you're going to a climate change
conference no it it was about how
different her trajectory was that she
was not subject to that line of
questioning and even given the
opportunity to use talking points that
someone else got you I was struck by two
elements of claudian Gay's statement
first and foremost that there was no
apology and they teach you to apologize
and also how important forgiveness is
and that we are a forgiving Society if
we're going back to Divinity School
routs so there was no apology about
letting down the academic community and
that's something that's really important
it's it's a small Club the Ivory Tower I
know people especially some people at
this table like to make fun of the Ivory
Tower but people work really hard to get
there and they take lowp paying jobs and
they kill themselves to publish multiple
papers a year to get the kind of
credentials to be able to go on to those
jobs the second part was no apology over
what I imagine she feels is a
misunderstanding of her stance on
anti-Semitism and the Jewish community
and to then turn the statement into
something about immutable
characteristics well guess what those
kids are being harassed because of
immutable characteristics not getting
into the whether Judaism is a race or
religion or whatever it is but you're
born a certain way right you're born a
Jew and they're having inata and
genocide chanted out of them at them
because of the way that they were born
and I thought that was really a missed
opportunity all future presidents of
these universities need to be subject to
this level of scrutiny they will be now
maybe probably I imagine and it lets
down people who is an opportunity Jesse
where President Biden could have a
sister Soldier moment and come out and
say this was wrong but he can't come out
and talk about
plagiarism he can't come out and talk
about anything Dana oh that's also yes
that's also true true um my sources at
Harvard told me my powerful monologue on
Harvard in December was kind of the
breaking point okay and the trustees had
heard enough and contemplated and
reflected over the Christmas vacation
and it was time to eliminate her power
my other sources are saying this is
about money and Harvard's just like a
hedge fund that happens to teach a few
classes they have a 50 billion doll
endowment and she just lost them a
billion dollars in 10 days that's what
you call a bad quarter Harvard can lose
its reputation but they can't lose its
money Dei is a Cancer and we have to
root it out through sunlight and we have
to expose it for what it is and it's by
discriminating against gender race even
ideology and we have to get back to what
made America great Merit and judging
people on their actions and Al Sharpton
a fraud who's defending a fraud is out
there saying that this woman was fired
because she was a black woman who
cracked the glass ceiling she used
someone else's head to crack it she
stole half of her scholarly work eight
out of the 17 published articles were
plagiarized and then Barack Obama who
actually saved a man from a plagiarism
Scandal is lobbying to save another
person from plagiarism is why are black
leaders in this country rallying around
other disgraced black Americans just
because they're black it's an
embarrassment is this like the OJ is
innocent situation it shouldn't be like
this we have to get back to what's
worked for a hundred years in this
country judging people on what they
produce and she's produced nothing she's
produced a loss of a billion dollars and
I'm sorry Harvard actually did the right
thing yeah they told everybody that it's
really about Merit and not about skin
color and now Jesse Jr will be applying
early decision but you do you do have to
admit that if you're going back hundreds
100 or 200 years that black people were
restricted from even getting into these
places they didn't even have a chance no
not a course for you but I wanted a
course from Jess I want they can hire a
very well-qualified
African-American woman to run Harvard as
long as she's not conservative as long
as she has to be she has to be on the
same
intellectual I bet they won't call coni
Rice yeah yeah or Dr Carol Swain she was
someone who I believe her she
plagiarized from yep also Jesse I think
that um one thing to point out on that
Al Sharpton statement here's a prime
time investigation waiting to happen
what he says is this is all about
corporations trying to get out of
billions of dollars of commitments that
they made to to Dei and that is a story
worth following because we follow the
money on that front the corporations are
saying we're done with this now and
that's coming from the top but also
maybe the bottom okay hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else